[Music]
hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we are going to do our
little react earth on catching up on
some trailers I want to make this clear
right now we've had some and some other
channels I know of to have had some you
know issues with covering Universal
distributed trailers so that's why we
didn't do ma or yesterday there we did
do reactions on the Stardust app for
them I know that's not us like you know
if they're in the moment doing it but we
do have our opinions there so we can
which download it falls in the starkest
at 30 second reaction reviews for any
film TV show or trailer well put Ives
our micro sketches post daily you can
post to tag us in them post there's a
lot of great people on there but we're
the best let's keep it in that homes I
was first I'm so that's why but these
are not you know Universal films but we
got three trailers here that we did not
cover this week and these are three that
have been requested heavily and we're
gonna just cover them in order of round
the time periods from the movies take
place so we have the kid which is a
Western so that's definitely the oldest
the Highwaymen which I hear is about
something with hunting down Bonnie and
Clyde and then triple frontier which I
believe takes place in the year three
thousand five futuristic sci-fi
strolling past a recent past in the
future if you want to just hop around
there were timestamps at the beginning
of this video that you could do some
hard work yourselves and just jump to
that moment watch the first reaction
just skip to the last review let's make
any sense let's get to it let's start
with the kid which is a Vincent
D'Onofrio directed fillet
oh you gotta play Billy the Kid Dane
everything is not awesome
hmm I am no cowboy is really shot that
what's the perfect western trailer music
damn
[Music]
they're real
[Music]
my lucky day
I got some nipple chills westerns like
three of the Magnificent Seven yeah
because Vincent and there's Chris Pratt
and then there's Ethan Hawke and there's
got to be at least one or two more like
smaller yeah that's true yeah absolutely
you like them the movies really about
the nephew or whatever that little kid
is or something or something because it
makes you have to think like oh this is
gonna be all about Billy the Kid but
there looks like it might be also about
this actual kid yeah who's kind of
caught in the middle of these things it
says the story of a young boy who
witnesses Billy the kids encounter would
Sheriff Pat Garrett
so is it like those those awful biopics
where they you know it's like I want to
see me about this guy but it's about the
dude who witnessed it's my weekend with
Marilyn or whatever or it's just like I
was thinking like those Bruce Lee movie
takes Bruce Lee's class and we learn all
about him through this way it seems like
a little more of a contained version of
the the assassination of Jesse James oh
yeah do you know what I mean of like
because that one's by the Coward Robert
Ford and it's but it's you know it's
focusing on Jesse James and maybe
perhaps it's actually one of those films
where it's like okay the kid so maybe
that's the play on words it's about the
young boy the kid but then it's also
yeah but it looks like the real stars
are I mean there's Dane DeHaan but I
feel like this trailer is really
capitalizing even on a curse
right yeah yeah and I was like the bad
guy in this which is pretty cool I mean
I never associate him as a other than
the beer that looks suspicious it
doesn't look like a real beer might be
but it doesn't look real to me feel like
it probably is not a big beard other
than that I mean Chris Pratt looks
really compelling in the role and very
different than anything else he's done
Ethan Hawke does fits so well with this
job he's built to play western
characters for sure I mean he can walk
around and kind of anytime in place so
I'm excited to see him just cuz he was
the performance from the trailer that
the most just kind of bowled me over it
was like yeah I can't wait to see that
but uh I don't know I think it's close
to Han gets to take on this cuz I feel
like he's had a hard time finding his
niche yeah like this could be a great
role for him and would be cool to see
Chris Pratt play a villain with awful
teeth yeah a lot of awful teeth in
westerns so throws the villains - yeah
so he's the villain so you forget to
brush em whatever they did back then to
keep their hands
that's like saving the cat but in the
old way yeah he smiles his teeth are
white we like him I feel like western
trailers often have like their trailers
are always cut to this kind of like rock
drums type of music they're always
advertised to me as like more badass
than the movies they actually ever end
up being because there's all those quiet
moments in between where people have
contemplated whist it's usually a drama
you know it's usually a drama with some
occasional like tense shootouts or zone
cuz even watching The Ballad of Buster
Scruggs went home yeah well that started
I was like oh [ __ ] so this movie
actually is like after
a lot of westerns or Lindy it was like
Magnificent Seven which are not as cool
of westerns because there's more about
the action and being cool yeah and I
don't know I feel like Vincent D'Onofrio
as he directed anything else I was
wondering that throughout this too cuz
it just they just threw out their
director Vincent D'Onofrio as if he was
as if he I mean with Bradley Cooper and
a star is born they kinda just threw it
out that way too okay so don't go in the
woods I yeah I remember hearing about
this so he has directed another film
before like yeah many years ago yeah
yeah yeah I remember
directorial debut and I totally forgot
well cool man I mean this he's I imagine
he is what's the word act in Active
Directory yeah an actor's director
because of the level of talent that man
has as an actor yeah and it's kind of
funny he's like barely in this trailer
but the level of talent he has as an
actor I'd imagine he's great at
directing the performances here but he
does look like he has a lot of style
here as well so I think this movie could
be something that's really cool and
that's that's something that always
excites me about westerns specifically
as I feel like people always bring a
distinct photography game to their
Western yeah so yeah very curious to see
how he has and not to mention Dane
DeHaan who is so sexy Dane DeHaan like
such a good actor who I just feel like
never gets the credit
never seems to get like the exact right
roles lately it's like it seems like he
gets a lot of projects that have mad
potential and don't hit yeah yeah I
don't know what even in this movie
that's the Billy the Kid movie I'm like
I mean like I don't know I see his
performance but it doesn't look like
it's showcasing him as much as the
shadow just showing I wonder what
audiences haven't been so receptive to
Dane DeHaan either when I think he when
I do feel like he is such a great actor
but yeah I don't control the way people
feel and we saw that Green Goblin stuff
yeah you ruined it for yourself Andrew
Garfield too
oh yeah let's move on to the next one
the Highwaymen alright so onto the
Highwaymen this movie is directed by
John Lee Hancock who has directed a lot
of true story movies and this is another
one of them the rookie the Alamo the
Blind Side saving mr. banks the founder
all gritty movies right so this is I saw
the description on I am deep Netflix's
for this about two officers humming I
kind of get I'm Bonnie and Clyde yeah
sounds like a really cool concept to me
yeah and you know Woody Harrelson loves
playing partners is gonna be Bonnie
Clyde Bishop time is a flat circle let's
check this out I'm actually this is
though this is out of all them this is
the one I'm most intrigued check out
because I was covering you hell yeah
yeah happy baby Bates to
just kidding expositions whoa these are
these are the trailer song every piece
is gonna have stomped yeah oh god damn
she's gone far enough I love the
mysterious element of Bonnie Claire is
so cool
my bikini how much range [ __ ] that's the
[ __ ] trailer music other theatrical
engagements that's a movie out we're
watching the video watch this in the
theatres yeah it's funny it seems like
these two trailers have had a theme of
the kind of Westar I mean this one has a
Western esque style about it it's also
about these like famous figures Amos at
like trying to deal with those famous
outlaws and like the situation yeah but
yeah like you pointed out I think it's
really cool the way they're really at
least in this trailer treating Bonnie
and Clyde with an air of mystery you're
not getting too close to them you're not
doing like the Michael Mann thing of
where you're like jumping in on both
protagonists and antagonists you're like
man but the outlaws are so much cooler
yeah here you're here with the with the
guys who are hunting them down and
you're doing alright they're the
badasses too you know there's something
that if I kind of intriguing about like
they're they're older what are they like
former oh they seem like they were
retired and then they're pulled back
into this or something or something so
it seems like they're pulled back into
this and I like that idea of like there
are older dudes and you know Kevin costs
a lot of times of these roles you feel
like you get guys who are like more in
shape or some [ __ ] like that with Kevin
cos is like pretty overweight here yeah
he's a body and he and he kind of has
this this presence with his with his
body language here it's got this
hard-boiled and he's good at you see
feel the history on him you feel like
he's been doing this a long time and
he's kind of burnt out by it but he's
still gonna do it you feel the toughness
of Woody Harrelson here but it's
interesting to me how well in true
detective
Woody Harrelson isn't as tough as if
you're just gonna look at that one
quality the tough part that it doesn't
look like Woody Harrelson is as tough as
Kevin Costner but he's still strong here
you know yeah but he always is playing
the supporting part
which is kind of a bummer yeah yeah man
but hey I mean there's something to be
said for a great support although it
would be nice to see him play the lead
maybe when that carnage movie finally
comes out well I think this this movie I
think Hema Koster is perfect for it
because Kevin Costner this genre he
seems to be like best in his something
of a Western and this isn't a Western
but there is sort of its Western vibes
to it and I think he does good in
periods stuff in general just like oh
yeah and I do like the idea of not
really seeing a lot of Bonnie and Clyde
but primarily through the praten like
the Bonnie and Clyde movie we even had
the the meal Hersh one now you know and
I just have been so many do
documentaries about them Bonnie and
Clyde are so covered and this is
actually a cool way to cover the story
from the perspective of the people
hunting them down and the production
design behind this all looks cool and
the violence looks awesome like all that
this looks like a really badass movie
yeah and one that's probably gonna at
least incorporate some of the historical
context because - you know you got the
the things of the newspapers and the
people marching through the streets and
the idea of what Bonnie and Clyde's
presence is doing to the people in
society yeah because they were you know
like this is Bonnie and Clyde were
around that time of people like you know
John Dillinger and stuff we're outlaws
were awesome you know and where these
guys are not so awesome and in the
public eye so it's like they even had
that one thing I think is in a water
tower where they're like go Bonnie
Claudia and that element of where
they're kind of the underdogs hey this
is this is really intriguing to me and
it's so smart not to feature Bonnie and
Clyde a lot because you I feel like it's
an audience or you would be like we just
check back in with them to restrict it
to the POV of like the people hunting
them like in a way like compared to the
last trailer with the device what the
kid could feel like a bit of a ringer or
something and this I feel like it off
the bat makes a lot of sense something
oh cool because that'll draw tension you
know and mystery and you're gonna yeah
them draw near to Bonnie and climb on
this feels more like what I wanted
Public Enemies to be yes
just throw some DV cams and you're good
yeah this looks like a badass time dude
and it was kind of funny looking at his
more recent films from the director of
The Blind Side yeah inspirational sports
field because I'm looking at the Alamo
which is the last movie he did that had
any kind of like action in 2004 you
should have seen the grease trap fryer
fight in the phone or when the author of
Mary Poppins and Walt Disney throw
fisticuffs on awesome this was a I was
most looking forward to and it did not
let me down yet so yeah alright one more
to go which I imagine will probably be
the best of them all but your flow
frontier
alright triple frontier I did see the
trailer for this for the first one I'm
just my own time and it looked pretty
cool has some of my favorite white
people in the world Ben Affleck Charlie
Hunnam and Garrett Hedlund I feel like
you get a badass yeah Pedro Pascal here
Oscar Isaac who worked with JC Chandor
the director of this in the most violent
year and apparently this director JC
Chandor
corner on tomatoes has never made a bad
movie yeah three for three in counting
so I'm pretty I'm pretty excited to
check this movie out this is like the
comedy that would probably get a limited
release to in the theaters because it
caliber the cats and there's action in
it and stuff you know yeah you also lied
to me this isn't a future war movie in
the year 3000 Special Forces and South
America or something in the okay this
made this video a lot more fun for me
I told you that this is the year 3000
[Music]
[Music]
definitely Charlie I'm talking all these
dudes is like an awesome gas that our
lives
nice dude throw that in there
[Music]
that is a lot of money yeah she should
take God
[Music]
how is this out of the feeders
okay there's our yeah Jesus look at that
movie this is gonna be the new norm for
them I think that we're not gonna put
these movies that clear I mean to be
seen on a big screen on the big screen
thing is not going this I mean this part
as part of the screaming wars especially
when you're you're trying to stay in the
game here like I've heard some
predictions that Netflix that if the
streaming wars might actually suffer the
most because they're already in debt and
they already that's so much money and
with everybody coming up with their own
streaming service a lot of stuff is
gonna leave so what they're trying to do
is appeal to prestige in a lot of
different ways like this isn't like
prestige Oscar or kind of territory this
movie by the theaters but it is a
theater yeah it's terrible time and now
put this in the theatres and it looks
crazy yeah I I wonder does this
something about the lines of this really
pitching this is like you know an action
movie which it looks like it is it's an
action movie I just feel like with this
kind of cast though I would want a
little bit more than just an action
movie yeah you know it's like it looks
like he had a lot of the the times were
are macho men are emotionally intense
and I like situational moments like that
in action movies where they are being
really affected by the tension and the
danger of the situation they're in but I
mean come on man but you know can also
act their asses off yeah like yeah at
least at least like as Mel's barely in
this trailer I know and I wonder if
maybe that means something but yeah I
guess I hope that this trailers may be
masking the amount of perhaps dialog
yeah cuz the aid the dog was very action
movie dialogue yeah and and the thing I
had a gripe about with this trailer is
just that
I'm sure the whole movie is more complex
than this but it started to feel like
okay so after a while the stakes are
just gonna be like this is not going
according to plan and there are a lot of
people come to kill us what do we do
all right well we just go through okay
well yeah well I feel like it could be
very effective at that though III think
that it seems like a very simple plot
which is cool it's and that's fine
and I think it can be effective but
right now I'm other than the fact of how
I'm you know I like I love this cast
this director has yet to make a bad
movie I am here going what about this is
is actually you know really unique yeah
where did you get all of these guys here
for yeah well bait all these guys what
is so distinct about this action movies
yeah exactly what makes this more than
like an Expendables but with more
prestigious actors like or actors more
prestigious for acting you know because
for some honestly for something like
this my expectations would be a little
bit higher in terms of I want this to be
more than just a solid action movie yeah
no totally for sure like there has to be
like either the most gripping emotional
intensity ever or oh [ __ ] did it not
advertise the kind of action that you
really get in the Train like in the
movie is that I feel like that way with
them kind of feel like that way with
most of the John wick trailers is you
watch those trailers like man they don't
really truly represent the kind of
action maybe but to see a prolonged
sequence of it is all yeah and maybe
that's a similar case here you know cuz
right now it looks like a pretty generic
by-the-numbers
action movie yeah yeah this looks like
the kind of thing that and funny enough
it's like if this had been like an eco
wise movie I feel like it would just
naturally have some emotional stuff in
it cuz they usually put those kinds of
tense stories and but like yeah if I
just wanted this to be an action
extravaganza I would want yeah just a
cast that's more oriented toward action
specifically that's not gonna make me go
can't wait for these guys to talk to
each other yeah well I think Eko why
it's like that movie
the night comes for us is a great
example of like that was a Netflix
produced move the Netflix distributed
movie and you watch the trailer for that
and it does not give you a anywhere how
[ __ ] insane yeah I'm kind of hoping
for a similar thing here where I watch
I'm like that movie was nuts I believe
this could do that because at least the
the brief moments of like actual
personal violence are very startling
when they're coming down the stairs when
they find out those are intense yeah
when he shoots that one guy coming in
like I was taken aback yeah that you
know and I like this heading to I mean
when they're like in the in the foliage
they're out in like the jungle area and
stuff like that it's like all dark and
Misty like it looks like it's got some
pretty cool you know setting aesthetic
all right well cool man
three trailers trailer is all
action-oriented in they're all very
masculine very testosterone-fueled very
dusty yeah bruisy triple frontier fits
the least in with them but you know it
still fits
yeah the modern-day crime we didn't
realize it but they're facing they're
all linked in a way you know they all do
link all right well which one of these
three are you guys most excited to check
out comment below let us know why and
before we wrap this up I want to give a
page of the day shout out to the man who
I talked so much about movies with an
extensive link our Scottish friend from
Scotland the Scott
Daniel Galica
this man right here he is the best
representation of all these movies that
we watch trailers for so masculine I see
him he is like that masculine kid like
Billy the Kid whoa you're like no man
he's that he's got that boyish charm but
you know he's a man at the same time
you're gonna break a lot of hearts and a
lot of kneecaps and yeah measure and
you're gonna find a woman just as badass
as you where you're gonna go on the run
like Bonnie and frickin kalai and then
she's gonna die so you're gonna join a
group of like equally bad ass Scottish
people like Gerard Butler oh yeah James
McAvoy
Craig Ferguson Craig Ferguson is the
most most bad of all of them is no he
encompasses three so three trailers
three actors he income like I'm saying
I'm saying our boy Daniel encompasses
three Danny Boy Danny Boy
these damn it I think Danny Boyle is
British [ __ ] him all right so oh I'm
gonna say right here that Daniel I would
love you so much and I hope that one day
you and I will be able to make a boy
band together none of this none this
macho [ __ ] let's let's form a boy group
because we need to bring those back I
grew up on that that kind of thing and I
feel like they're only in Korea now yeah
so let's bring it to Scotland we can
really even arrive five dudes singing to
one girl in Scotland I can't wait for
that day anyway guys thanks for being
here subscribe for the reject nation
click that notification bell and check
us on Stardust a PA